[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et leurs deux points de
vue merci d'être fidèle à notre rendez
vous quotidien nous accueillons ce soir
rasch et le bénin bonsoir vous êtes
journaliste
on retrouve notamment vos articles dans
les hebdomadaires marianne et l'express
on vous retrouve aussi régulièrement sur
l'antenne de lci
et puis georges kuzmanovic et là aussi
bons soient ravis de vous retrouver vous
avez été un des porte parole de la
france insoumise vous êtes aujourd'hui
le président du mouvement république
souveraine que vous avez fondé en 2019
et qui défend des idées d'un
souverainisme de gauche pour faire court
on peut faire les choses on est aux
chevènementistes voilà absolument néo
chevènementiste quel beau programme
nous commençons si vous le voulez bien
cette émission avec un hymne qui ne
passe pas inaperçu c'est celui de
l'équipe de france de football on
connaît désormais la composition de
l'équipe
révélés par didier deschamps on connaît
aussi la chanson officielle
ça s'appelle écrit mon nom en bleu
jusque là rien de très original il très
transgressif
sauf que
cet hymne il est chanté par le rappeur
youssoupha on va en parler mais on en
écoute pour commencer quelques notes
écrit mon oncle crime aux bleus n'a que
crime on en bleu et puis mon nom ample
crime on en bleu note kim hommes en bleu
un défendre les lignes et les voilà
youssoupha est donc un rappeur qui s'est
notamment rendu célèbre pour des
chansons pas exactement consensuelle
par exemple un titre qui date de 2009
ça s'appelle ça s'appelait à force de le
dire et il y chante et notamment je mets
un billet sur la tête de celui qui fera
taire ce con d'eric zemmour on pourrait
considérer ça comme une menace peut être
même une menace de mort eric zemmour
avait d'ailleurs poursuivi le rappeur
pour cela mais ces poursuites ont été
considérés sans fondement par la justice
et puis il ya une autre chanson éternel
recommencement c'était sur le premier
album de youssoupha et il y disait je
mélange mes fantasmes et mes peines
comme dans ce rêve oumma semences de
[ __ ] foot en cloque cette chienne de
marine le pen c'est parole passé n'ont
pas échappé en particulier aux
responsables du rassemblement national
écouter jordan bardella le vice
président du parti
il était hier sur france info ce qui me
choque moi si vous voulez c'est la
chanson qui a été choisi pour l'euro
notamment la chanson de youssoupha parce
que youssoupha et quelqu'un qui dansait
dans ses chansons dans les champs
extrêmement virulent qu'il a des paroles
virulentes lorsqu'il appelle par exemple
lorsqu'il appelle à des menaces de mort
contre eric zemmour
lorsque par exemple il a extrait propos
extrêmement virulente à l'égard de
marine moi ça me choque qu'on choisisse
quelqu'un comme ça si vous voulez pour
représenter la france à l'euro en
matière musicale
alors on notera qu'il n'ya pas que le
rassemblement national qui conserve qui
conteste ce choix regardez par exemple
ce tweet de notre confrère eric naulleau
qui regrette
une chanson tout pourri ça c'est sur
l'hymne de lui-même
et puis qui rappelle les propos tenus
par youssoupha sur marine le pen et eric
zemmour a quand même des gens qui le
défendent
le choix de cet hymne et de son chanteur
en particulier la ministre chargée des
sports roxana maracineanu qui était ce
matin sur france info écoute et
youssoupha c'est un rappeur qui est
populaire qui est engagée aussi contre
le racisme qui a des convictions
la fédération de football l'êtes aussi
bien sûr quand on parle d'une femme de
cette manière là je ne peux que ne pas
être d'accord
maintenant c'est aussi pour dénoncer les
propos de marine le pen en terme de
racisme
et vous avez vu la toute toute les
personnes qui s'expriment d'un seul coup
comme ça sur le football c'est
clairement instrumentaliser le sport
instrumentaliser le football voilà on
verra pas forcément beaucoup
d'enthousiasmé dans la défense de la
ministre mais en tout cas elle assume
rachid benaïssa est ce que vous avez été
choqué par par ce choix et j'ai été
surtout sauter par l'hymne en lui-même
que je trouve particulièrement mauvais
pour tout vous dire depuis la ferme être
dreams et son hommage à verdun pour la
première guerre mondiale
plus grand chose qui me choque ou du
moins qui nous qui me surprend ensuite
alors au risque de vous décevoir je
trouve que le procès est un petit peu
rapide concernant youssoupha je
m'explique je pense qu'ici on est face à
un à certains égards ce qui compte ce
qui relève du fantasme on va dire du
rappeur gangster
en réalité il ne couche pas beaucoup de
cases qui appartiennent à cette
catégorie là on lui reproche et je peux
entendre des propos qu'il a tenus il ya
dix ou quinze ans dans le cadre d'une
d'une chanson vous l'avez d'ailleurs
disant que rempart en particulier pour
les propos sur eric zemmour que c'était
du deuxième degré et qu' il fallait pas
le prendre comme étant ce qu il y en
avait publié une tribune d'ailleurs à ce
sujet dans le monde justement pour s'en
expliquer et pour dire aussi la peur
qu'il avait eue après en se demandant
est ce qu est ce qu il ya des gens qui
vont vraiment prendre la chose au
sérieux et au premier degré etc
ça bon moi je suis plutôt une partisane
de la liberté d'expression aussi bien
quand elle concerne eric zemmour quand
elle concerne youssoupha ensuite y'a des
tribunaux la cour d'appel s'est exprimé
elle a considéré qu'il n'y avait pas
lieu de condamner c'est une chose
youssoupha en quelques mots brièvement
pour décrire un petit peu de qui on
parle on parle de quelqu'un qui a été
toujours été très bons élèves
ça peut paraître comme ça un petit peu
accessoire mais je pense pas que ça ne
le soit qui a eu qui a été mon cas
poursuit des études littéraires
meilleures notes de l'académie de
versailles au bac
pas de casier il a poursuivi des études
ensuite à la sorbonne bac + 5
aucun lien ne connais aucun lien avec
des mouvances dit islamistes donc il
connaît le foot c'est pas rien non plus
donc je je je pense qu'il faut faire
attention
je comprends qu'on a un petit peu dans
la continuité de la sphère benzema mais
on est loin quand on parle de youssoupha
on est loin de la figure d'une racaille
vraiment pas c'est pas le cas
j pas que ça n'existe pas dans le monde
du rap loin de là mais lui celui des
roches à ce que certains considèrent
être une règle
est-ce que l'argumentation trachée
menace vous convainc georges kuzmanovic
oui je suis d'accord avec eux c'est ce
que vient dire à chelles et puis la
france et le sait le pays de la deuxième
chance alors certes il a eu des propos
inacceptables
beaucoup en ont eu effectivement il est
à regretter mais vous savez aussi après
la deuxième guerre mondiale
la france a récupéré beaucoup de ces
très grands artistes qui avait plus que
l'insulté des gens qui avaient collaboré
au moins n'avait pas fait grand chose
pendant la résistance parfois avait
chanté ou où s'était compromis avec avec
l'occupant allemand nazi
on leur a pardonné ils ont bien
représenté la france après par contre
maintenant ça va lui donner
responsabilités parce que non seulement
il a composé cette chanson mais moi je
trouve assez intéressant quand même
parce que j'écris ton nom en bleu
alors musicalement c'est moi ce serait
la seule critique que je ferai c'est
musicalement parce qu'on va avoir un
moment collectif populaire nationale
l'euro est là on va voir qu'une chanson
qui va être difficile à chanter parce
que c'est justement c'est du rap et donc
c'est scandé et c'est bon ça va être un
petit peu compliqué mais pas contre
j'écris ton nom en bleu en prenant des
des français qui composent l'équipe de
france mais qui viennent avec des images
en arrière fond qui viennent des
quartiers qui viennent des villages de
france
bah c'est intéressant je trouve que
c'est un ça fait un moment un moment
d'union et et puis je voudrais lier ça à
la sphère qui a eu à laval le livreur de
livres ou qui a été insulté traiter deux
esclaves alors c'était terrible et c'est
très bien tout le monde s'indigne un je
crois il est allé porter plainte
sa plainte a été reçue par la police et
il a dit que c'est la première fois que
ça lui arrive en 12 ans et bien moi je
trouve que le choix de youssoupha cet
événement mais ça nous montre que ceux
qui nous disent que la france est un
pays qui est systématiquement racistes
ont tort et que on doit combattre contre
les deux extrêmes exemple extrême droite
c'est repos qui pour certains sont
racistes ou extrême gauche qui utilisent
le racialisme américain ce sont des
diviseurs et là on a un peu d'être un
moment de d'union un petit peu comme en
98 parce qu'on va avoir une attaque de
feu à ce mondial karim benzema benzema
pzero essai du si je me suis je si on
reprend les classifications justement
des racialiste à l'américaine on a à
nouveau du black blanc beur voilà tout
le monde va être va représenter la
france et ça va nous permettre en étant
black blanc beur de rappeler que la
france n'est pas une couleur de peau
sinon c'est une couleur de coeur de
langues histoire commune de culture et
on a un moment où possibilité d'écrire
un moment de notre histoire alors votre
propos tout en vous intéressant à tous
les deux qu'il n'est pas vraiment en
accord avec le point de vue de nos
internautes que ça va permettre de
nourrir leur réflexion puisque c'est la
question du jour sur le site du figaro
approuvez-vous le choix du rappeur
youssoupha pour l'hymne officiel des
bleus et c'est non
à 87% il y a
et puis on vous pose également la
question sur twitter la réponse est
négative aussi mais pas tout à fait dans
les mêmes proportions
puisque c'est non à 73% je vous donne
quelques commentaires d'internautes gcd
c'est la pauvreté du texte coupé à la
médiocre qualité vocale de ce chanteur
et il met des guillemets font que c'est
un très mauvais choix
alain qui nous dit mais si on est contre
ce choix on doit aussi être contre la
coupe du monde au qatar dont on connaît
les affres commises lors de la
construction des stades envers les
ouvriers immigrés youssoupha c'est un
choix idéologique tout comme le retour
de benzema affirme linars et la
tentative de refaire 1998 et puis
anonymes qui nous dit si cela choque des
parties de divisions comme le rn alors
oui youssoupha est un bon choix
moi je voulais vous donner mon point de
vue je pense que tu une mauvaise idée
alors je me prononce pas sur la qualité
de la de la chanson parce que toute
façon moi juste totalement imperméable
au rap donc j'essaie toujours d'éviter
de parler des sujets que je connais pas
sûr sur le bonhomme je trouve que la
comparaison avec les artistes de la
collaboration est pas complètement
pertinente parce que ils ne
représentaient pas la france après la
guerre ils ont recommencé à faire du
cinéma de la chanson mais là c'est
l'hymne de officiel de l'équipe de
france de football et je trouve qu'on
aurait dû choisir une personnalité plus
consensuel j'entends chez rachel quand
vous dites mais c'est du second degré
certes vous avez contextualiser mais le
français de bonne foi quand il voit les
phrases que je vous ai rappelé il se dit
mais pourquoi on a choisi ce bonhomme là
je peux comprendre mais je crois qu'en
fait c'est parce que ça s'inscrit dans
un contexte un petit peu plus large je
dis pas que ce que vous dites est faux
car si on prend des barrages ou youssouf
a en fait ce choix là ça répond en effet
à une partie des supporters du foot on
va pas se cacher à mon sens qu'elle vous
êtes d'accord pas consensuelle -
peut-être que johnny en 2002 maintenant
pour la qualité de la chanson de johnny
en 2011 pour aussi en reparler c'est
peut-être pas aussi consensuel mais ça
l'est pour toute une partie des
supporteurs parce que parce que je
souffre assez
je souffre à wallace et c'est un rappeur
on peut croire que le rap est peut-être
un peu plus un petit peu plus prégnant
dans des banlieues ou dans des quartiers
etc
c'est des gens qui sont aussi de
fervents supporters les meilleurs
joueurs c'est aussi des gens qui
viennent de banlieue les meilleurs
joueurs de foot je pense qu'en fait
c'est ça fait quoi plusieurs choses qui
nous dérange et qui peuvent tous
tellement se comprendre c'est que la
musique
de toute façon à évoluer l'europe
aujourd'hui c'est devenu la pop d'hier
pour aller vite même quasiment de la
variété c'est pas acceptée par tous
et ça peut ça peut se comprendre le foot
à certains égards c'est aussi un peu ras
kaïser si je puis dire avec les
guillemets que ça nécessite on le voit à
travers un certain nombre d'affaires
ces dernières années et en plus de ça le
niveau général a baissé comme en
témoigne cette chanson mais c'est un
petit peu facile de tirer sur youssoupha
qui selon moi est peut-être le symptôme
de mots qui sont qui sont beaucoup plus
vastes beaucoup plus variés et encore
une fois
autant je pouvais comprendre l'émotion
et l'indignation
quant au choix de m gims youssoupha
n'est pas maître gims georges tron avait
de quoi il ya une innovation marketing
c'est à dire en gros derrière les choix
de benzema ou de youssoupha ya la
volonté de plaire une certaine catégorie
de français pour benzema non un benzema
les cinq meilleurs joueurs au monde et
on va effectivement si le trio arrive à
s'entendre
je parle de lego pas des origines et
qu'il y aura plein de quels sont les
deux autres parce que là je suis
incapable de commenter ou deux de
compléter votre robot mbappé je revois
la vallée giraud c'est à dire l'attaqué
l'équipe de l'attaqué meilleure attaque
au monde
enfin si on opère une véritable
véritable rouleau compresseur bossis
illégaux se mélangent pas la dent donc
le choix de benzema est parfaitement et
est excellent je trouve que l'attitude
de deschamps a été parfaite en tant qu'
en tant que chef
de cette équipe de france il a puni et
ils pardonnent voilà il dit mais vous
pouvez être le meilleur
si vous rentrez pas si vous n'êtes pas
dans un collectif y est vous ne jouerez
pas pour l'équipe de france la leçon je
pense a été retenu est sûr que je m'en
bas on aurait peut-être pu trouver ami
rappeur y avait bien un peu moins seul
ivan non on a juste sur benzema encore
et j'ai dit alors que la france est une
couleur de coeur benzema mais ça c'est
l'occasion aussi de ne plus ressortir
que ça coule son drapeau de coeur c'est
le drapeau algérien
il est représentant de la france il est
français et c'est ça c'est ça c'est ça
la simulation à la française
et c'est tant mieux maintenant pour
youssoupha je suis pas un grand
spécialiste en rap il est quand même
très populaire vous l'avez dit il m
il aime lui-même le foot
voilà je vous ai dit cédric enfin je
n'arrive pas à trouver de problèmes de
là dedans et moi ce que je pense
compte tenu des tensions qu'on a dans la
société il est plus intéressant
d'essayer de se redonner tous
collectivement des secondes chances
plutôt que de cliver oui on peut dire ça
c'est un [ __ ] il a dit ça tel jour etc
mais ça sera l'état d'esprit des réseaux
sociaux mais aussi un choix politique il
faut le dire
c'est aussi un champ politique de la
part d'un gouvernement qui a envie de
plaire à une certaine catégorie de
personnes
en même temps ce gouvernement que je
n'apprécie pas du tout et j'ai de faire
comment changer parce qu'il est détruit
la france mais en même temps on va lui
dire alors il va manifester avec le
policier c'est pour ces pour lui
complaire à l'extrême droite puis le
lendemain à y laisser il a choisi
youssoupha c'est pour complaire à l
écoute comme bon mais mais peut-être que
pour youssoupha ya plus qu'un plus un
coup de com et je pense que le plus
c'est la chance donnée à ce qu on est
bien on considère - la france certes
inconsciemment la france comme un pays
systématiquement insiste le débat
continue à vous passionner sur les
réseaux sociaux
floriano qui nous dit pourquoi pas
soprano qui est beaucoup moins clivant
cet hymne est pas du tout fédérateur
cinar considère au contraire que
youssoupha est un artiste qui prône la
paix et de bonne valeur donc
je ne vois pas de soucis particuliers
chardons bleus pensent au contraire que
c'est de la provocation et josiane qui
ne tolère pas la vulgarité de ces mots
je pense dit elle qu'il veut faire du
buzz démarche politique
rachel bidasses en ce moment il ya
beaucoup de clins d'oeil à la jeunesse
il ya ce pass culture qui vient d'être
annoncé 300 euros pour tous les jeunes
de 18 ans pour aller au cinéma ou
acheter des livres au revoir ça marche
pas pour netflix nîmes pour amazon c'est
un peu balisé le procès en la république
qui nous va nous sortir sa vidéo avec mc
fly et carlito les deux vidéastes bien
connu des amateurs de youtube vous voyez
là une espèce de france yves en règle
bien sûr c'est difficile de dire de dire
le contraire
d'ailleurs c'est quasiment pas à masquer
n'ont pas caché je crois que ils
avancent eux à peu près à visage à
visage découvert quand il je parle des
membres du gouvernement
on peut aussi parler de rapprochement
avec avec cyril hanouna le présentateur
donc en effet cette volonté de séduire
de faire du pied un électorat jeune
c'est une manière de ratisser large
c'est-à-dire à la fois pour organiser
les premières élections macron à
dépouiller on le sait le ps
maintenant il s'en prend à l air et puis
et puis bien sûr la jeunesse en tentant
de les mobiliser à vos réservoirs de
voix potentielles pour pour marron autre
sujet qui n'a vraiment rien à voir mais
qu on avait aussi envie de traiter avec
vous ce soir
la loi sur la sécurité globale vous vous
souvenez sans doute de ce projet est
porté au parlement par le ministre de
l'intérieur gérald darmanin et notamment
du célèbre article 24 articles qui
pénalisait la diffusion malveillantes
d'image des forces de l'ordre certains
considéraient que c'était une sorte
d'interdiction de filmer les policiers
notamment pendant les manifestations cet
article 24 est devenu l'article 52 dans
la loi qui a été votée par le parlement
mais cet article ce fameux article vient
d'être censurée par le conseil
constitutionnel qui considèrent qu'il
méconnaît le principe de la légalité des
délits et des peines
est ce un camouflet pour le gouvernement
vous allez nous le dira en tout cas ça
tombe mal
car les policiers on le sait était très
attaché à cet article et au fait qu' il
ne puisse pas être être filmé contre
leur gré et leurs images diffusées de
façon hostile
donc le gouvernement va tout faire pour
essayer de de produire un autre article
écoutez gabriela talent le porte parole
du gouvernement
ce que je veux dire aux policiers c'est
qu'évidemment le ministre de l'intérieur
gérald darmanin va faire des
propositions au premier ministre pour
tenir compte des réserves ou de censure
qui ont été faites par le conseil
constitutionnel
évidemment notre ambition de mieux
protéger nos forces de l'ordre elle
demeure évidemment nous chercherons à
adapter notre droit et à tenir compte de
cette décision du conseil
constitutionnel pour poursuivre nos
objectifs sur twitter nous vous posons
la question le rejet de la loi sécurité
globale par le conseil constitutionnel
constitue-t-il un échec pour le
gouvernement
eh bien vous répondez oui à 75% je vous
donne les points de vue de deux
internautes avant d'écouter ceux de nos
invités
chris kraus oui c'est un échec defacto
giovanni sur youtube
considéré au contraire que cette loi
était une grave atteinte aux libertés
individuelles et que c'est un
soulagement qu'elle ait été rejetée
cela dit peut-être que giovanni
considère aussi que le fiasco pour le
gouvernement est un soulagement mais ça
on ne le sait pas georges kuzmanovic
est-ce que à la place du conseil
constitutionnel vous auriez vous aussi
censuré cet article je pense que oui en
raison de la déclaration des droits de
l'homme et des élus et du citoyen de
1789 qui sont qui en préambule de toutes
nos constitutions et dans notre
constitution actuelle il est clairement
établi à l'article 2 de cette
constitution
un des principes de ce qui est bon dans
le libéralisme c'est la défense de
l'individu contre l'arbitraire ça
s'appelle la sûreté qu'on confond
souvent avec les sécurité tant que la
sécurité est un besoin dans la société
pour se prémunir des criminels mais la
sûreté c'est la protection de l'individu
contre l'arbitraire du pouvoir s'est
développé dans l'article 7 où il est
clairement dit que on doit obéir aux
représentants de l'ordre quand il
demande mais par contre ils ne peuvent
pas usé
lors de leur pouvoir de violence
légitime comme on dit à mauvais escient
et donc il faut pouvoir le critiquer
c'est une liberté fondamentale dans une
société libérale et puis c'est un vrai
échec pour ce gouvernement parce que
bien évidemment cela renvoie à l'un des
grands scandales de cette de cette
présidence c'est la sphère benalla sait
toujours pas où il est cet ajout pas où
est le coffre et un coffre qui se
baladent avec des armes dedans est une
histoire rocambolesque avec l'allemagne
avait fait passer pour un policier
oui ces violences qui n'était pas
forcément légitime qui n'était
absolument pas légitime puisque c'est
déguisé en policier bien on a découvert
que bon enfin qu'il avait pu faire tout
un tas de choses parfaitement illégal se
balader avec des voitures de police
accédez aux informations de policiers
bon tout ça a été révélée parce que
quelqu'un a filmé que qu'on aime bien
mais j'étais aboaf c'est une autre chose
mais il l'a filmé mais ça et ça a permis
de révéler ce scandale il y en a eu il y
en a eu d'autres
et puis dans un contexte généralisé
alors eh bien qu'il n'y ait pas de
comparaison entre la france des
etats-unis mais la sphère de georges
floyd a été révélée parce que des gens
filmés et puis d'une certaine manière
c'est une loi impraticable on se bat là
tout soin tous des téléphones dans les
gens filment tout le temps tout et
n'importe quoi c'est quasiment
impossible à interdire dans les faits et
puis on a des dispositions légales pour
punir ce qui est dévoilerait des
adresses ou souhaiteraient nuire à
anneaux à nos forces de l'ordre
c'est le bénin à ces deux questions en
une un ace que cette décision du
conceptionnelle vous semble légitime et
2 est ce que c'est un échec politique
pour le gouvernement elle me semble
légitime parce que parce qu'elle est
motivée parce que visiblement logis
slater n'avait pas défini suffisamment
les éléments
les éléments constitutifs de
l'infraction dont il y avait un flou
c'est vrai qu'il y avait un flou et
c'était assez prévisible quand vous
lisez le texte des mots pas défini du
tout un manque de rigueur quand même
assez important
ensuite la seconde question est ce que
c'est un camouflet oui ça en est un je
peux entendre comprendre que le texte
puisse être qu'un texte de manière
générale puisse être un parfait et bien
sûr le conseil constitutionnel est là
maintenant je pense que le le le vrai
sujet autour de cette loi c'est surtout
que qu'elle avait quelque chose de tri
cosmétiques
c'est à dire que elle n'avait de
sécurité globale que le nom elle porte
sur des choses en fait sur lesquels on a
déjà légiféré qui on est persona le
juridique
on a tout l'arsenal mais pour nous
éviter de en fait en réalité d'aborder
le problème les problèmes de fond que
rencontre réellement la police les
besoins sison ben on a recours comme ça
au droit on nous pond cette loi qui
coûtent pas énormément en tout cas on
pense et qui repose encore une fois sur
des éléments qui sont déjà constitutif
d'une infraction article 39 de la loi du
29 juillet 1981 on ne peut pas filmer et
diffuser des images d'un fonctionnaire
etc
je vais pas vous faire la liste
milliards du code civil au code de
procédure pénale à cette loi
suffisamment justement de d'articles et
même la jurisprudence pour pouvoir faire
face à ces situations mais la police
elle n'a pas les moyens de faire face à
la justice n'a pas non plus les moyens
de faire face
donc je pense qu'en fait cette loi et c
était une dans une petite escroquerie
sur le fond parce que c'est là qu'est le
problème on a on a les moyens d'agir
contre la criminalité et contre le
terrorisme on manque de volonté
politique et donc le politique plutôt
que d'agir en dirigeants feront des lois
pour faire semblant qu'il n'est qu'ils
agissent mais je suis étonné qu'on ait
fait cette fois et puis que ce
gouvernement ne finance pas plus la
justice deux fois moins financés que
comme elle même deux fois moins de
magistrats il ya des progrès quand même
le budget de la justice était tombé
mental est sensible 2
m parquet antiterroriste estime mais
comme quoi ce que vous expliquez que
cette loi parfois de manière très peu
motivée contre eux venaient au liées à
la protection de l'individu et c'est en
réalité les éléments existent déjà et on
n'est pas dans un régime autoritaire est
par contre un vrai fantasme g chez
emmanuel macron un fantasme de type 1984
orwelliens parce qu'il ya des
discussions sur les sur les drones
il ya eu discussion sur des logiciels de
reconnaissance faciale adro une
reconnaissance faciale on est en chine
moi je suis pas sûr que ce soit
exactement la culture de notre pays
non ça sera après la france et
l'élection oui mais je suis pas sûr que
les français dans leur ensemble veulent
être fliqué à ce point et qu'on soit
aussi peu efficace contre certains
aspects du terrorisme qui je m'en étonne
terrorisme non mais ne sont pas abordées
du tout dans votre mémoire
ça ne semble pas intéresser les
financiers qui viennent du qatar
d'arabie saoudite ou ou ceux qui ont des
complaisance coupable ou les manques de
moyens pour la justice antiterroriste
alors ce qui est intéressant c'est que
vous êtes d'accord tous les deux sur ce
sujet comme sur le précédent
c'est à dire que vous pensez que le cos
et cautionnait la a bien fait alors moi
je suis pas d'accord avec vous donc je
vous ai cru mais les arguments je suis
ravi ça me donne ça m'en donne
l'occasion
moi je suis très réservé voire assez
critique sur ses décisions du conseil
constitutionnel qui sont prises non pas
sur des éléments de droit concret mais
sur une évaluation totalement subjective
par rapport aux grands principes tout
accroc en gros le consul conçue elle dit
l'équilibré entre la nécessité de la
sécurité publique et les droits
fondamentaux du citoyen ne sont pas
respectés ou mais c'est son avis
attendez je termine juste c'est son avis
c'est la vie d'un conseil qui est
présidé par un ancien premier ministre
de françois mitterrand laurent fabius et
moi je trouve que le conseil
constitutionnel en l'occurrence fait de
la politique et je suis choqué par cette
espèce de gouvernement des juges il me
semble qu'il n'a pas la légitimité pour
une décision comme celle là mais c'est
mon point de vue c'est ce que j'ai dit
tout à l'heure je pense que c'est ça a
été le grand progrès des droits de
l'individu dans l'histoire depuis
le magna carta l'habeas corpus a choqué
par cette espèce de gouvernement des
juges vos quêtes à autre chose le
gouvernement des juges me pose un grave
problème
je pense qu'il faudrait le réformer
pleinement mais là on a un sujet
spécifique entre sécurité et sûreté et
la sûreté est un acquis libéral de
longue date qui commence en une fois en
grande-bretagne avec jean sans terre
le frère de richard coeur de lion les
droits de ce sont les droits de
l'individu contre l'arbitraire il me
semble que vous avez été un fervent
combattant en tout cas intellectuelle de
contre contre l'urss où justement
l'occident incarne quand même malgré des
à énormément de défauts cet avantage
spécifique qui est la défense de des
droits de l'individu allait donc je
pense que philosophiquement oui des lois
qui empêcherait c'est ce droit de
l'individu face à des forces de police
dirigée par un exécutif la
philosophiquement je vais bien sûr
passer la parole à hnb voilà où je suis
pas d'accord avec vous c'est que moi je
considère que la défense des droits le
premier droit c'est le droit de vivre en
sécurité
le premier droit dans une démocratie
c'est celui d'avoir une police qui est
protégé et il me semble que le
gouvernement qui est lui-même et le
représentant d'une majorité élue
démocratiquement doit pouvoir faire des
choix et qu'il n'est pas logique qu'une
cour suprême puisse les censurer mais
encore une fois c'est un point de vue
rachel vinasse je te rejoins votre
jugement un tout petit peu sévère parce
que en réalité il me semble dans le
texte le conseil constitutionnel dit que
l'intention est louable
or là déjà il fait de la politique ne
peut être que là parce que là ça dérange
pas mais indiqué que cette intention est
louable mais qu' il ya des manques
vraiment les éléments quand on dit
provocation comprend pas vraiment à quoi
on fait référence etc
il ya un flou peut-être que quelque part
c'est un mal pour un bien
parce que à un moment il faudrait que le
gouvernement ou les gouvernements fait
successifs successifs par dont 16 comme
ça de de joie au serpent de contourner
véritablement les problèmes en nous
pondant à chaque fois une nouvelle loi
alors même qu'on à l'arsenal légiste
tige pour lutter et s'attaquer aux
problèmes de fond mais parce que c'est
ça en réalité que réclament les
policiers c'est plus de moyens c'est une
augmentation des effectifs
c'est peut-être même une meilleure
formation mais mais là quelque part on
pense plaire aux forces de l'ordre sans
réellement traité le problème dans le
fond je pense que c'est une erreur
et quelque part peut être tant mieux que
le conseil constitutionnel et les
retoquer violent toi je vous tends n'a
pas tout de suite mais nos internautes
qui sont de plain pied dans le débat ont
des interventions qui comme toujours
mais là je trouve de façon
particulièrement vive intervention très
intéressante celle de mikko sur youtube
qui est d'accord avec vous georgie qui
dit cette loi est contraire aux
fondements même de la constitution le
pouvoir s'efforce d'apporter des
modifications aux interprétations en
surface seulement et puis ingrid dont je
vais d'accueil plutôt d'accord avec moi
donc je l'en remercie sur youtube
c'est un échec pour la france le conseil
constitutionnel est devenu une machine
théologique qui agit contre les français
et puis ce commentaire de citoyens
payeurs sur lefigaro.fr
rien que le nom de sécurité globale
c'est le nom donc eux qui a été donnée à
cette fois ça fait doucement rire quand
on constate l'insécurité ambiante
quotidienne et puis benjamin sur youtube
c'est surtout un échec du conseil
constitutionnel qui ne protège pas de
policiers bref le débat est animé tant
mieux georges kuzmanovic vous disiez et
certains internautes donc qu'il ya un
problème de protection de la police pour
être policier c'est un métier
extrêmement difficile parce que perd de
plus en plus non de moins en moins non
jean et policiers au 10ème siècle
pourquoi pas entré dans l'histoire de
police il ya eu des moments extrêmement
difficiles en fin de trouver un point de
désaccord entre vous un avion
extrêmement sellama si la fin d'émission
mais je voulais beaucoup plus de morts
il ya deux décennies dans les rangs de
la police qu'aujourd'hui par balles pour
perdre non ce qui est ce qui ce qui
manque c'est un métier difficile parce
que c'est lui la défense qui essaie
comme les militaires qui va protéger les
militaires briens et -qui celle qui au
risque de leur vie défend les spurs
c'est pour ça que c'est une profession
honorable et qui doit être salué parce
qu'ils prennent sur leurs dos ce risque
là et certains en paye le prix le prix
de la vie maintenant ce qui pose
problème je pense aux policiers c'est
que non pas qu'il faudrait avoir un
contrôle sur la justice mais que la
justice manque de moyens et qui est des
juges qui veulent bien faire mais ils
ont des dossiers comme ça qui s'empilent
souvent renvoi des criminels ou
finissent finissent pas en prison parce
qu'il n'a pas les moyens de juger on a
deux fois moins de magistrats qu'en
allemagne on aime bien prendre allemagne
et dernière chose
et dernière chose que je passe et
laissez passer par la chaîne l'émission
est terminée avec deux lots je vous
promets en or fera des débats sur est ce
que le problème de la police et la
justice comme le prétendent certains
responsables syndicaux
merci infiniment à tous les deux parce
que c'était passionnant et merci à vous
de nous avoir suivi il n'y aura pas de
point de vue lundi lundi de pentecôte
oblige mais ce sera un bonheur de vous
retrouver mardi prochain à la même heure
et au même endroit très bon week-end
d'ici là